there's a lot of times there's a lot of
situations in which we're studying
something pretty straightforward and we
can find an exact theoretical
probability so what am I talking about
let me write that down
theoretical theoretical probability
well maybe the simplest example or one
of the simplest examples is if you're
flipping a coin and let's say in theory
you're flipping a completely fair coin
and you're you're flipping it in a way
that is completely fair well there you
know you have two outcomes the coin will
either result either heads will be on
top or head tails will be on top and so
theoretically you say well look if I
want to figure out the probability of
getting a heads in theory I have two
equally likely possibilities and heads
is one of those two equally likely
possibilities so you have a 1/2
probability and once again if in theory
the coin is definitely fair it's a fair
coin and it's flipped in a very fair way
then this is true you have a 1/2
you have a 1/2 probability we could also
do that with rolling a die a fair
six-sided die is going to have six
possible outcomes one two three four
five and six and if you said what is the
probability of rolling a or getting a
result that is greater than or equal to
three well we have six equally likely
possibilities you see them there and in
theory if once again if they're all
equally likely four of these
possibilities meet our constraint of
being greater than or equal to three so
we have four out of the six equal of
these possibilities meet our constraints
so we have a two-thirds four six is the
same thing as 2/3 probability of it
happening now these are for simple
things like die or flipping a coin and
if you have fancy computers or
spreadsheets you can even say hey I'm
going to flip a coin a bunch of times
and do all the competent orcs and all
that but there are things that are even
beyond what what a computer can find the
exact theoretical probability let's say
you're playing a game say say football
American football and you wanted to
figure out the probability of scoring a
certain number of points
well that isn't very simple because
that's going to involve what human
beings are doing minds are very
predictable how people will respond to
things the weather might get involved
there might be someone might fall sick
the ball might be wet or you know just
how the ball might interact with some
players the jersey who knows what
actually might might might might
actually result in the score being a one
you know one point this way or seven
points this way or seven points that way
and so for situations like that it makes
more sense to think more in terms of
experimental probability an experimental
probability we're really just trying to
get an estimate of something happening
based on data and experience that we've
had in the past so for example let's say
that you had this is you social this is
data from your football team and since
it's a couple of games or many games
into the season and you've been
tabulating the number of points you have
a histogram of the number of games that
scored between 0 9 points your two games
it scored between 0 9 points for games
that scored between 10 and 19 points
included or 10 from 10 to 19 points you
have 5 games that went from 20 to 29
points you had three games that went
from 30 to 39 points and then you had
two games that go to from 40 to 49
points now let's say for your next game
and let's say you've already had two
let's see how many games you've had so
far this is to let me write it down the
game so far is two plus four plus five
plus three plus two so this is what six
plus this is 6 plus 5 is 11 11 plus 5 is
16 so you've had 16 games so far this
season and you're curious for your 17th
games let me write this game game 17 you
want to figure out what is the
probability of scoring scoring scoring
let's say score let's say your score
let's say your points your points are
greater than or equal to 30 your points
are greater than or equal to 30 for game
17 so once again this is very hard to
find the exact theoretical probability
you don't know exactly you can't predict
the future you don't know who's going to
show up sick how humans are going to
inter
with each other maybe someone screamed
something in the stand that just phases
the quarterback and exactly the right or
the wrong way you don't know this is
incredibly incredibly complex system how
what might happen over the course of an
entire football game but you can
estimate what will happen based on what
you'll see in your past experience and
it depends on the defense of the team
you're facing and all that so it's not
going to be you know it's not going to
be super exact but you can estimate
based on experiments based on what
you've seen in the past here the
experimental probability and I would say
the probability the estimate because I
would I don't you know don't you you
shouldn't walk away saying this okay we
absolutely know for sure that if we
conducted this next game experiment end
times it's definitely going to turn out
the same thing this might be the
toughest gate defense that you play all
year this might be the easiest defense
that you play all year but if you look
at what's happened in the past out of
the 16 games so far there have been
three games these three plus these two
games where you scored more than greater
than or equal to 30 points so five out
of the sixteen situations you scored
more than that so an estimate of your
probability and then you could view this
as your experimental probability of
scoring more than thirty points based on
past experience based on past experience
is five five out of the sixteen games
you've done this in the past so you'd
say it's five sixteen now I want to
really have you take this with a grain
of salt you should not you know then go
good say okay I know for sure there's a
5/16 probability of us winning this game
because you only have some data points
every team you play is going to be
different it's going to be different
weather conditions people are going to
be in different moods etc etc this is
really just an estimate I actually I I
feel even a little bit of reservations
even calling it a probability I would
just say that this has been true of five
out of 16 games in the past so it's an
indicator of what might what might be
what you know you might say okay no
based on experience it's more likely
than not that we don't score more than
thirty points but it's really just based
on experiential data what's happened in
the season you know even the makeup of
your football team might have changed
you might have gotten a different coach
you might have learned to train better
who knows one of your team members might
have grown by 3 inches all of these
things so all of this has to be taken
with a grain of salt but this is one way
of thinking about at least having a
sense of what may happen